pidgins our fine feathered city-dwelling
friends some refer to them as rats with
wings others trash doves but none be
known to most people there's some of the
most interesting and intelligent
creatures that we just so happened to
share the sidewalk with every day
whether they're manually guiding
missiles during World War two or
inexplicably navigating back to their
nests hundreds of miles away to deliver
messages pigeons have a long and
fascinating history of working with
humans believe it or not the common Rock
dove like Daisy here is actually the
world's oldest domesticated bird they've
been around humans ever since ancient
Egypt roughly around the same time as
the invention of the wheel and now after
thousands of years they're finally
getting attention through a way they've
always deserved video games one of the
biggest and most recent inclusions of
pigeons and games has been in Marvel's
spider-man you will find the birds
scattered all over the sprawling New
York metropolis just as you would in any
major city land on a rooftop and
eventually a flock of pigeons will join
you nothing too surprising there but
when spider-man's friend Howard needs
help finding a dozen of his wife's lost
birds we get to see pigeons from a whole
new perspective the side mission is a
touching tribute to the once vilified
birds and even gives us all a more
sympathetic look at the relationship
some humans have built with pigeons now
that she's gone they're yours I
definitely know however the pigeons and
spider-man are more than just a
sought-after collectible they're also
there to teach you how to be a better
spider-man after the first few hours in
the game you know how to swing you know
how to basically get around the city
with your website empowers but you're
never actually taught how to go fast
that is until you encounter the pigeons
Chase is on they zoom around the city
skyline so quickly you're sometimes left
wondering if it's even possible to catch
them at all but then something clicks
you learn how to dive to gain speed you
figure out how to maneuver around
corners and you finally combine all that
you know into a singular grand spectacle
of agility and precision all for a
pigeon so fun fact there are actually a
bunch of different pigeon types out
there you know you have your typical
rock doves but you also have your ring
necks your fan tails your king pigeons
you know the list goes on now into here
is a homing pigeon and they're bred to
be stronger and faster than your typical
city bird this little guy is actually
missing a part of his wings so he's not
gonna be doing any flying but birds like
him can reach speeds of up to 60 miles
an hour which is probably why they're so
hard to catch in game spider-man might
be one of the biggest games in recent
memory to have showcased the birds but
it's far from the first Grand Theft Auto
4 took a very rockstar approach to the
games 200 hidden packages they were
pigeons yes sadly you had to shoot the
birds in order to collect the packages
but at least you got a nice helicopter
out of it going from New York to New
dunk
Super Mario Odyssey gave us a small
pigeon cameo in its Metro Kingdom let
Mario take a load off on a bench in the
city and a pigeon would eventually swoop
down and perch on his nose all right
hold sail perfect 2016's battlefield one
took the portrayal of pigeons to new
heights and managed to capture the birds
importance early on in the 20th century
at that point in time people were using
them to send messages capture
photographs and during the first world
war
save lives pigeon headquarters barracks
for the signal cars feathered messenger
soldiers smallest members of our army
armies would routinely release pigeons
in order to notify allies of their
positions with the most famous account
coming in 1918 when the pigeon by the
name of Cheramie flew through enemy
gunfire and single-handedly saved the
lives of nearly 200 US soldiers its leg
was actually badly injured during the
flight
so maybe single footed Lee would be a
better word the game feature a couple of
historical nods to these brave war
pigeons
including a mode where teams battle for
possession of a messenger bird as well
as a breathtaking moment from the
campaign where players took control of a
pigeon flying over the pockmarked
European war front finally it's almost
impossible to talk about pigeons and
video games without mentioning the game
that really put pigeons in the spotlight
hot - full boyfriend the 2011 avian
dating simulator saw us choosing from a
handful of handsome doves to woo or
maybe I should say COO the game showed
off a whole flock of different birds
some species in the spotlight for the
very first time you could court the
pudgy Partridge shoo or romance the
fancy white plumage of the fantail
pigeon with Yuya or go with the shiny
iridescent feathers of the octave with
Ryota the game's wildly absurd premise
also came coupled with impeccable
writing and a surprising amount of heart
quickly winning people over with its
animal magnetism and proving that there
really isn't a limit to what dating sims
can accomplish now it might be a while
before pigeons reach the level of
popularity of parrots or owls but their
inclusion in some of the biggest games
around is really promising for the
reputation battlefield one reminded us
that even during wartime humans aren't
the only heroes pata fo boyfriend let us
fallen over the birds in ways we never
would have dreamed of in spider-man
prove that pigeons can teach us more
about the cities we know and love as
well as the people that inhabit them
let's face it humans and pigeons were
made for each other and hopefully video
games can continue our storied
relationship for years to come
[Music]
everyone hope you enjoyed this video and
maybe even learned a thing or two about
pigeons and I think there's some of the
coolest Birds around so if you want to
learn more or maybe even help needy
Birds you can visit pigeon rescue org
for more information and maybe even
consider adopting a pair alright thank
so much for watching we'll see it wonder
what he thinks just being brought up and
down fun fact
pigeons are actually tiny dinosaurs
always she's like it's okay